tato a mocha hoodie a moody Arkham a the
2010 2011 Canterbury earthquakes caused
widespread and unprecedented damage
across the Greater Christchurch area the
way mccurdy district kaiapoi high rocky
and the pines beach had over a hundred
hectares more than a fifth of its
population classified as residential red
zone why Makka Delhi district council
was directed by the Minister for the
earthquake recovery to prepare a draft
recovery plan identifying users from
Ashland both for an interim period and a
longer term the council saw this as an
opportunity to work with the community
and other stakeholders to regenerate
these areas throughout the process the
council actively involved the community
from primary school kids through to the
elderly we work with residents central
government no Tahu and nigh to our food
ed to ensure that everyone had a chance
to contribute to the final proposal we
had five regeneration areas to consider
and it was important that there was a
coordinated approach to the use of this
land social economic cultural and
environmental needs were all considered
council also had to ensure the proposal
was practical provided the community
with value for investment and took into
account the resilience of the land
itself the finalized plan reflected the
need to provide certainty for the
community while allowing flexibility for
the long-term implementation and
management of the agreed land uses
pleasingly the plan was reviewed and
accepted by the Minister for earthquake
recovery Gerry Brownlee he described as
comprehensive for public participation
which had led to the final design and
expressed confidence in its long-term
success by being an inclusive process
from start to finish means that we are
leaving a commonly agreed legacy for our
children and future generations to come
the other boy p to you